sub JJ what's going on my mouse just
playing destiny new DLC is our next week
so I want to level up my guy a bit sweet
knee strikes and stuff and story
missions finally closure there was story
in destiny I thought it was shoot aliens
for the hell of it
Oh child if anything destinies universe
was about as in-depth and intricate is
the one that George Lucas made for Star
Wars without the trade negotiations if
you've got two minutes I can tell you
all about it yeah right in the near
distant future in a galaxy far far away
well it's actually archiving humanity
finds a giant white orb thing floating
in the sky this traveler uses a guy with
the dulcet tones of British actor Bill
Nye to communicate with others the
traveler is an awesome celestial body
that kicks off the Golden Age of
humanity lifespan is increased we
explore the solar system make some cool
tech and we colonize new planets the
traveler gives off light it's a kind of
mysterious power yeah yeah I watched the
intro movie to shush I'm giving context
everything's coming up millhouse for
humanity until the brain boxes at a
research facility on Venus discover that
ancient cyborg bodies the vex are living
in every planet like a dormant wasp nest
not only that but humanity discovers
that their fine piece of Mars
real-estate freehold sits on top of the
entrance to the black garden the realm
where the vex are produced on mass and
then it all properly goes to hell
generic other alien things the high roll
in and take over the moon the Golden Age
is truly over as the vex wake up and
other halo s aliens the Cabal and the
Fallen decide to join in on the attack
the fancy blue awoken awakened and
defeats some of the Fallen and claim
their soldiers because they are helpful
like that so there's this great battle
in which the traveler gets damaged it
creates ghosts stinkle BOTS yes the very
same to find those who can wield the
travelers light it's a magical power
don't question it as a weapon to save
the traveller and humanity but if the
traveler isn't fixed by the time the
last dinklebot dies then we are screwed
the humans get pushed back to earth and
end up cowering
under the travelers protection in the
last safe city you know that place all
the shops are they start infighting and
then Bill Nighy is all know we must work
together to save the traveler which is
where you come in as a guardian you can
wield the light of the traveler and go
on adventures with your dinklebot shards
of the traveler are scattered around the
place and the hive are using them to SAP
its light power thing on the moon you
discovered that all light is connected
well might technically functions as both
a wave and a particle so damn how did
you get in here reality check Friday's
game vodka so Bill Nye sends you
Guardians out into the galaxy to find
the traveler shards and stop them from
being infected by darkness ripping out
the heart of the black garden how do you
rip the heart out of a realm shut up
it's a game and destroying relics that
are being infected by darkness will let
the traveler heal so you go do that I
think that's what the holding square bit
is but there's some politics has the
awoken want to use the black garden
rather than destroy it
I mean you destroy it anyway and at the
end traveller begins to heal you
see then you get this fancy light thing
for doing all that
now that the travel is healthy it's
pumping out more light and that means
you can level up and that's how we're
getting DLC and stuff okay that was
slightly over two minutes but that's so
far you sure that was in the game huh
clearly someone didn't log on to Bungie
don't let in read their grimoire cards
there were cards yeah anyway
join me next week as I head back in time
to tackle the order 1886 who are you
talking to you
sup JJ what's going on sorry yeah we
forgotten if you've got two minutes I
can tell you all about it get you up to
speed
huh that's all good les Magnus with
smugness isn't on you're thirsty its
assertiveness I'm asserting my eyes yeah
oh oh
other side yep what you see in the walk
just did that it went black slide